Emilia Tebow I love pizza
okay there I said it I love pizzas so
much that I'm wearing it today as you
can see it's a beautiful day in New York
so I thought it's the perfect day to
track down something I saw on Instagram
are you [ __ ] kidding me
look this is what happens when the two
titles of food makes sweet sweet love to
each other and have a baby cheeseburger
and pizza and of course this pizza comes
from Vinny's in Brooklyn which at this
point is basically a pizzeria crossed
with a mad scientist's laboratory now I
would dare go on this journey by myself
so I'm gonna grab a friend so I just
knocked out the chair
we are off the subway headed over to
Vinnie's gonna eat some pizza with
cheeseburgers on it what the hell is
that we're about to be there soon and I
have a feeling this is gonna be a [ __ ]
ton of food when's the last time you had
people last night I'm actually curious
to see if the cheeseburgers gonna be too
much too much topping on the pizza I
mean I don't know if you can't have -
come on keep up with me man can you be
there in five minutes
come on burgers do it there she is
coming up on the homestretch I see it
where is it
[Music]
my name's Henry Taunton we're at baby's
pizzeria in Greenpoint Brooklyn my
inspiration for the cheeseburger few
take aim for music Mondelez melting pots
and madness remixes and mashups best of
both worlds so we make a Benny's
original large cheese pizza we grow up
the burgers put the burgers and the
American cheese on the pie right when it
comes out pop that back in the oven let
the cheese melt then when it comes out
top it with the bun and then add the
garnishes which are ketchup mustard
white onions and
the other place putting pizza I don't
want to eat it so much time and effort
to make this so pretty look at how
perfect that just pops out I will say
tesam week two
and let me tell you something I don't
even know what's happening migraine
cannot process I will say I'm about half
way through one slice in the midst of
the meat it's starting to sweat this
doesn't work if it's not good pizza and
it is I am so pleasantly surprised by
this here we are just having the last
bite of a slice I look up and Jade is
even though the slice is presented a
certain way that you can kind of take it
apart you're like oh I don't want onions
here I'd rather have the pickle on this
bite to anyone who called Jade a quitter
better take your words back
I kind of feel like that's all we got in
us we came we've fought pretty hard
Jade's asleep we just left Vinny's we've
got our to-go box here today when I
first got it that thing is just like it
definitely takes a lot of stomach room
like you said you go in hungry and you
think you're gonna eat a lot of it you
get one slice in on that guy you're
going down
[Music]